To find the origin of Malthus, the malefic
demon from hell’s deepest crevices, we must
look back to the ancient texts that first
detailed the infernal entity’s name: The
Devil’s Welcome.
One page, studied by Mia Form in Annabelle,
tells of the Rite of Evocation, or the ceremony
of calling upon an evil spirit, demon or deity.
It says there is a fragment of the Dead Sea
Scrolls entitled “Curses of Belial” which
tells of the existence of demons. The Dead
Sea Scrolls are ancient Jewish manuscripts
found in Qumran Caves on the Dead Sea’s
western bank, so this book is suggesting that
there is actually a long lost piece called
Curses of Belial, reflecting the sentiments
shared by demons to prey on weak souls.
Belial is a real term referenced in several
religious texts, which some religions have
personified as The Devil. So when Mia reads
about how Belial was thought to have influenced
sin through the way people addressed him and
all his guilty lot, she’s essentially learning
that the other demons mentioned in this fragment,
including Valak, Malthus and others all answer
to Belial.
The Dead Sea Scrolls were discovered in 1947
and thought to be 1800 to 2000 years old,
making them the oldest copies of biblical
text ever discovered. If we take those dates
and apply them to the Conjuring universe,
we can estimate that the earliest recorded
text about Malthus was written around 20 BCE.
We’ll probably never know the actual creation
date of the demon, because this is as far
as it’s lore goes back. But that’s good
enough for me to put a date in the thumbnail.
To learn about the ENTIRE history of the presence
that made this creepy children’s toy famous,
including how it may become the most powerful
being in the Conjuring universe, stick around
to the end of this video.
Welcome to Horror History. My name is Professor
CZsWorld. What do they call me? A YouTuber,
an influencer, a creator.
“Something inhuman.”
Something like that. Today’s lesson is Malthus,
who is most notably the antagonist of the
Annabelle spin-offs. Like many Conjuring villains,
Malthus is based on mythological folklore.
The Lesser Key of Solomon is a 17th century
spellbook on demonology that contains details
about many of the demons found in popular
fiction, including Paimon from Hereditary
and Valak from The Conjuring 2. It’s divided
up into five titles. Ars Goetia focuses on
the practice of conjuring demons, so naturally,
it serves as a major source of lore for The
Conjuring franchise.
It contains 72 demons, each one serving some
kind of role in the hierarchy of Hell. There
are Kings, Dukes, Princes, Marquises, Knights,
Presidents, and Earls. Malthus is considered
an Earl of Hell.
Also sometimes known as Halphas, this demon
is not associated with the ram form as portrayed
in the movies, but rather as a wicked storc
with a hoarse voice. I just Malthus having the voice of Jeff Garlin.
*Jeff Garlin laughter*
Halphas is known for building up towns to
house weapons and ammunition for his 26 legions
of warrior demons, which he can send to attack
wherever he pleases.
We see this concept realized in a different
way in Annabelle, where Malthus is the subject
of evocation for, not an army, but a cult
known as The Disciples of Ram. Let’s get
into the demon’s early interactions with
mankind.
For as long as there have been religious entities,
those entities have had followers. Malthus’s
followers are a cult known as Disciples of
the Ram, a reference to the rarely seen true
form of the creature, a humanoid figure with
a ram-like horns. It also possesses long claw-like
fingers and charcoal-black features, which
are explained by Annabelle director John Leonetti:
“I wanted it to be like this thing had been
in Hell and it was jet-black, charred like
he’s really been in Hell and that was the
visual inspiration for it.”
He’s also got a beautiful goatee. That one
gets the CZ stamp of approval. Malthus is
your traditional gargoyle looking demon, which
works to thematically tie the character into
this idea of a religious clash. Which takes
me back to his milieu.
The evocation page, (the page that explains
the summoning of the demon) mentions that
an incantation is to be performed with spilled
blood. We can’t see the entire text, but
it looks like the summoner should be both
impious and uncleanly. Looking at the two
Disciples of Ram who perform the ritual in
Annabelle, I’d say they check those boxes
pretty neatly. Especially the uncleanly part.
Let’s move ahead to the chapter specifically
about Malthus and his Disciples of the Ram.
This passage lays out the rules. In Layman’s
terms, in order for Malthus to take a soul
and possess a body, the victim must agree
to give it up. Once the deal is made, it’s
everlasting, and the church fears this, because
if the demon tricks someone into doing this,
there’s not really much they can do to fix
it.
“Which brings us to the three stages of
demonic activity: Infestation, oppression
and possession.”
Why don’t I have a projector screen like
that? Ed explains the first stage, infestation...
“That's the whispering, the footsteps, the
feeling of another presence...which ultimately
grows into oppression, the second stage.
This is definitely the case for Malthus, whose
targets include an orphan who is treated differently
by the other girls for her disability, a new
mother who spends her days alone due to her
husband’s busy work schedule, a nurse who
can't say no to helping people, and a student
who is desperate to make contact with her
deceased father.
“Breaks the victim down. Crushes their will.
And, once in a weakened state, leads them
to the third and final stage: possession.”
The Devil’s Welcome also explains a couple
more rules. As I mentioned, blood must be
shed to summon him, but this is only to be
done as a sacrifice to Malthus. Whatever creature
is sacrificed is not to be used for food,
unless it’s meat given to them by the demon
specifically for food.
The last paragraph on the page says ”And
the bow shall be in the Earth, and I will
establish my covenant unto thee, which I have
made between me and thee, for every living
creature of all flesh that shall be upon this
Earth.” So he’s saying that he wants to
take all the souls and possess every living
creature on the planet. So basically the same
thing that the music industry is trying to
do.
There’s a graphic on the right labeled Malthus,
Earl of Hell, the only time the antagonist
is ever mentioned by name in the series, and
the picture shows the ram demon grabbing this
baby, which represents a common tactic he’s
known to use. By putting a baby in danger,
he can sometimes pressure a naive mother into
offering her soul in exchange for the child’s
safety.
JOHN: “But you said that it can’t take Lia’s,
you said that it has to be offered.”
FATHER PEREZ: “Yes, and a baby can not offer it’s soul.”
JOHN: “Oh my God. Mia.”
This wouldn’t be the only clever tactic
of deception used by the demon.
FATHER PEREZ: “The devil is the father of lies. Demons
are his manipulators. No one ever plans to
offer their soul.”
This presence would infest many homes over
the years, and each of them taught the fiend
some new tricks, that it would carry on to
it’s next target, meaning if it isn’t
contained, it could become more and more deceptive,
making it more and more powerful. We will
pick up on some of these tricks as we follow
Malthus’s journey through history.
Malthus’s earliest known targets were The
Mullins Family, Samuel and Esther. They lost
their 7 year old daughter Annabelle “Bee”
Mullins to a car accident in 1943, so Malthus
tried to manipulate them as they were mourning.
The young girl’s diary was abruptly cut
short, but after many nights, a new message
appeared: “Dear Diary. Today I came home.”
“Annabelle Comes Home. Rated R.”
Not yet, Annabelle Comes Home. We’re still
on Annabelle: Creation.
It all started one night during dinner when
they heard Bee’s favorite record start playing
randomly, and assumed it was her spirit.
They noticed more and more activity that mimicked
the things that their daughter used to do,
and eventually they found a note, asking for
their permission to move into this doll so
that she could be with them forever, and they
happily agreed.
This was not the spirit of their deceased
daughter, however, and by falling for this
trick and having faith that they could speak
to Bee again, the evil entity got stronger.
Soon, it could use the form of the Mullins
girl. They were able to see what they thought
was her ghost in fleeting glimpses. This was
stage 1: infestation.
“But we soon realized it wasn’t our Annabelle
at all.”
“Demons. What do they want?”
“A soul. And they won’t stop until they
get one.”
Mrs. Mullins decided to approach one of the
apparitions with a cross, but what appeared
to be her daughter convulsed and twisted itself
into a demonic form. She dropped the cross
in shock and Malthus attacked her, scarring
her face and taking out her left eye.
As the girl’s mother, Mrs. Mullins was the
most psychologically vulnerable. This was
stage 2: oppression. It had used her hope
of speaking to her daughter again to make
an attempt at her soul. Samuel reached out
to the church, and they saved Mrs. Mullins
from potentially being possessed, but the
evil was still attached to the doll, so it
was locked away in Bee’s closet and surrounded
by Bible pages, a cross and doused with holy
water.
The demonic activity would cease, but the
Mullins’ did not realize the room would
have to continuously be blessed in order for
the seal to remain strong.
Four years later, in 1947, The Dead Sea Scroll
is discovered, and the word of Disciples of
Ram would soon spread to the troubled group
of people that would start the cult.
Another 8 years go by, and Mr. Mullins and
his wife decide to take in a group of girls
from St. Eustace Orphanage. They believed
that sheltering these girls would be their
penance, but they unknowingly gave Malthus
exactly what it wanted: a new, weaker target
whose soul was ripe for possession.
“It’s been quiet for 12 years…”
The strange activity would begin again after
the girls moved in in 1955.
The new target  is Janice, a young girl who is partially immobilized
by polio. After discovering her, Malthus uses
the form of Bee to sneak up on her and give
her a fright. At dinner the first night, the
lights flicker, a sign that the evil is no
longer contained to that single closet.
That night, it leaves Janice a note reading
“Find Me” -- referencing a game that Bee
used to play with her father. Janice is led
into Bee’s room, which is supposed to be
locked. Malthus has left the key to the closet
for her to find and discover the hiding place
of the doll. It makes her uncomfortable, so
she covers it up and attempts to lock it away,
but when her back is turned, the inhuman spirit
appears behind her, but when the sheet is
removed, Malthus is in a form not visible
to the human eye.
More scary stuff begins to happen around the
house. Linda sees the doll move on it’s
own while playing hide and seek, and a mask
wearing form resembling Mrs. Mullins scares
the girls, disappearing as the light is turned
on.
“That wasn’t a ghost. Ghosts can only
be of dead people.”
One night Janice is lured back into Bee’s
room, where she catches an apparition, asking
for her help.
“Can you help me?”
“What do you need?”
“YOUR SOUL!”
Malthus proceeds to drag her around, leaving
a laceration on her leg. She manages to escape
the room, but Malthus slams all of the bedroom
doors so that she can’t get help, leaving her
no option but to go for the stairlift. Isolating
the target to make her feel alone seems to
be a common tactic for Malthus.
She looks up and sees the evil exiting room
in what appears to be a gaseous form. This
is the only time we see the demon travel like
this, but I can only assume that this is how
it usually gets around, to be able to travel
through walls and perhaps to change itself
into multiple forms.
Janet’s chair stalls ¾ of the way down,
so she tries to get up and crawl to safety
on her own. The last thing she sees is the
form of Bee, standing at the top of the stairs,
before she is AIR YEETED high into the foyer
air then dropped onto the cold hard floor.
She later admits to Sister Charlotte, who
is in charge of all of the orphans, that she
believes the presence is preying on her because
she is the weakest, but Charlotte disagrees,
telling her that the devil preys on those
weak of faith, not weak of flesh or bone.
The night she returns from the hospital, her
friend Linda has a few scary experiences with
Malthus. She looks through the keyhole to
Bee’s room and sees the Annabelle doll using
the rocking chair, but when she opens the
door, it’s nowhere to be seen.
Then, as she’s playing with a ball shooter
in her room, the invisible entity grabs it
and raises it to the top of the doorframe
before yanking it from her hands. She hears
loud footsteps… or perhaps hoofsteps, running
towards her, so she hides in her top bunk
and listens, as the lights are turned off
and Malthus inhabits the lower bunk, leaving
behind charred black footsteps, another sign
of the burning the creature would have endured
in the deepest layers of hell.
Linda looks down and sees Annabelle staring
back up at her, and she hides under the covers
after seeing Malthus, in it’s true demonic
form.
At this point, Janice, Linda, and the two
older girls, Carol and Nancy have all had
scary experiences with Malthus, but it has
not yet attempted to possess any of them.
I think the demon is testing each of the girls
to see whose faith is the weakest.
Janice is the weakest of body, but it’s
possible that this also led to her faith being
weakened. As she becomes older and more crippled,
she realizes no family will want to take in
a broken child and that idea is demoralizing
for her.
She’s also dealing with the fact that she’s
treated differently than the other girls due
to her condition, and this makes her an easy
target, because the demonic attacks can be
explained away as Janice lashing out as a
response to what she’s going through emotionally.
She is at that age where her hormones can
take over her emotions, an age that is commonly
associated with attracting a poltergeist,
because the spirits are said to be attracted
to the negative feelings that come with nearing
those teenage years.
The next day, Sister Charlotte takes her out
into the sunlight, and Malthus makes up its
mind about who to try to possess first. It
takes the form of a Nun, something we’ve
seen many times from its European counterpart,
Valak. The creepy nun is a popular form for
these demons to take, because it represents
an attack on the victim’s religious belief,
much like how the ominous knocking in The
Conjuring always comes in threes as an insult
to the holy trinity.
This creepy nun shoves Janice out of her wheelchair
and into the barn, where it reverts to the
form of Bee, to crawl out of the shadows and
begin stage 3: possession. In The Conjurverse,
you basically just have to puke in someone’s
mouth to possess them… I guess. I think
Malthus essentially just made Janice give
up at this point. She had just gotten back
from the hospital and already, she was going
to have another demonic encounter and probably
another injury.
With one victim possessed, Malthus had achieved
its goal, but remember the text in The Devil’s
Welcome: to “establish covenant” onto
the people and “for every living creature,
of all flesh that shall be upon the Earth.”
In other words, Malthus will now use Janice
to try to possess the bodies of the others,
then keep expanding out until the whole world
is taken over.
For it’s next target, Malthus wants to take
advantage of the element of surprise, so when
Sister Charlotte comes in to check on her,
Janice pretends to be fine. But with the added
power of Janice, the ram demon decides to
try again with a target it was unable to possess
13 years ago.
Mr. Mullins is alerted to the return of the
Annabelle doll from Linda, and goes inside
to find it ready to face him in his kitchen.
But the doll is not actually possessed by
Malthus, the demon only moves it around to
give the appearance of possession. As explained
later on by Lorraine Warren…
“Demonic spirits don't possess things, they
possess people.”
Janice does her best Lights Out Diana impersonation,
and transforms into its traditional gargoyle
or ram demon form, which I’ll be referring
to as it’s “true” form because that’s
what I picture in my head when I think about
a demon.
This time, even holding up a cross is not
enough to protect him from the evil. I think
it’s a combination of Malthus gaining power
by possessing Janice and the fact that his
cross is home-made and he admits that it isn’t
his best work.
Malthus brutally breaks off each of his fingers
one by one, forcing him to drop the cross
before moving in on him. Even if Mr. Mullins
supposedly wasn’t using his best cross,
it still speaks volumes to the power of Malthus.
We never see any of the other Conjuring villains
do anything like this. The scene represents
the power of belief.
It’s a common trope for religious people
to claim that they found religion after a
personal tragedy. For Mr. Mullins, losing
his daughter created the negative energy that
initially attracted Malthus. So the idea of
turning to religion is used in a literal sense,
where bible pages and holy water are used
to seal the demon away. So now the movie is
showing us that letting go of religion, literally
dropping the cross, has opened him back up
to being vulnerable to Malthus.
Linda realizes that the evil presence seems
to be connected to the creepy doll, and tries
to discard it in the well. Look Linda, just
because it worked for Coraline doesn’t mean
it’s gonna work for you.
She once again hears heads hooves march up
behind her the closer she gets to the well.
After dropping it in, she hears a small voice
call out, “help me”. It’s hard to tell
for sure, but it seems to be Bee’s voice,
so this is probably Malthus, once again trying
to mislead her by making her think that Bee’s
soul is trapped in the doll or something.
It nearly works, because Linda is practically
dragged into the well by a pale pair of hands
with long fingers. This doesn’t appear to
be Bee or Janice. It could be the hands of
the Nun form I mentioned earlier, or it’s
possible there were other forms acquired before
Bee.
With the help of Sister Charlotte, Linda is
saved, and the well is covered, but when they
return to the house, the Annabelle doll is
back on the couch where Janice had just been
sleeping. Charlotte takes the doll into Mrs.
Mullins’s room, looking for answers, and
her reaction speaks to the terror that it
brought her 12 years ago.
“No! NO! Get that thing away from me!”
She claims that the evil has returned, calling
it “the devil itself,” which is probably
not accurate based on what we know from The
Devil’s Welcome. Malthus is just one of
many demons working under the devil, Belial.
With the demonic nature of the haunting now
revealed, Malthus can no longer rely on deception
to possess it’s victims, so with the game-plan
out the window, it just launches a full on
offensive attack.
At this point, we have multiple things going
on in multiple locations. I would still attribute
all of this activity to Malthus, but because
Janice is still alive and possessed by Malthus,
she’s essentially programmed to act on its
behalf. So Janice can be upstairs terrorizing
the other orphans, while, Malthus is downstairs,
using whatever form it wants to torment Mrs.
Mullins.
So Nancy, Carol and Tierney find Janice having
tea with the Annabelle doll and Janice attacks
Nancy. Sister Charlotte attempts to dispel
the demon using prayer, so Janice air yeets
her into a mirror. The girls try to scream
for help, but Janice has another idea.
“Or, you could help me?”
Meanwhile, Malthus cuts Mrs. Mullins in half,
crucifies her to the wall and rings her bell
to try to lure the girls into the room. They
are horrified by what they find, and try to
flee the property using Mr. Mullins’s truck,
where they encounter a scarecrow with the
ability to move on it’s own.
Using the rules about these demons that have
been established, we can guess that this is
another one of Malthus’s tricks. Just like
with the Annabelle doll, the scarecrow is
not possessed, but simply moved around to
give the impression of possession.
The girls try to hide in the barn, but Carol
gets locked in alone, where she encounters
the scarecrow. Again, it’s in a position
reminiscent of a crucifix, and again, it ties
back into Malthus making a mockery of religious
symbols. She discovers the demonic true form
hiding inside the scarecrow, and it busts
out, climbs to the ceiling, and descends upon
her, but she’s able to get away to the toy
shop, where Nancy finds her.
In the house, Linda discovers the remains
of Mrs. Mullins, which jolt to life and come
after her, so she hides in the dumbwaiter,
which Janice is able to crawl through to come
after her. She sees the claw of Malthus’s
true form grasp onto the platform, meaning
that both the possessed Janice and the demon
itself are coming after her.
She hides in the “blessed” closet where
Annabelle had once been sealed by the priest,
but Janice finds her. Sister Charlotte is
able to rescue her once again by throwing
her cross necklace around Janice and locking
her into the closet. I think it’s quite
fitting that Malthus is continually foiled
by an actual Nun.
The pain caused by these religious items causes
Malthus to go crazy, causing the house to
shake, lights to flicker, electronics to glitch,
furniture to fly all around and glass to shatter.
The demonic growl can even be heard from outside
the house as Malthus, despite the pain this
might have caused, penetrates the bible page
plastered wall allowing Janice to disappear
into the night. Only the Annabelle doll and
Sister Charlotte’s necklace are left behind.
It appears that Malthus maybe stays with the
doll though, because after Father Massey blesses
the house, the doll is sent away with the
police. The Father claims that the evil is
gone, and the doll is now just a doll, but
after being moved to a new bible-page-lined
room, Annabelle is still under the control
of an external force.
It seems that Malthus stayed with the doll
by choice. It’s later described by paranormal
expert Ed Warren, who explains that the demonic
force is “latched onto” the doll.
Of course, it’s never explicitly explained
why, but I would guess it’s for one of two
reasons. Perhaps Malthus saw value in remaining
with the Annabelle doll because it had proven
itself successful as a way to trick people.
Or maybe there’s actually some kind of bond
being formed between the evil deity and this
handmade toy, in the same way that Ed Warren
describes the items in his cursed artifact
room.
REPORTER: “Why not just throw them in an incinerator?
Destroy them."
ED: “Well, that would only destroy the vessel.
Sometimes it's better to keep the genie in
the bottle.”
Janice somehow ends up at St. Joachim Orphanage,
where she’s adopted by a couple named Mr.
and Mrs. Higgins. She takes on the name Annabelle,
the actual first name of Bee. Although she
is still possessed, she doesn’t immediately
take on an evil persona, instead, becoming
more and more horrible over the next couple
years before eventually running away from
home to join a cult.
Of course, the cult she joins is The Disciples
of Ram, the Charles Manson led group dedicated
to summoning Malthus. She gets a crazy looking
cultist boyfriend, and although this part
of the story isn’t shown on screen, I’m
guessing it’s no coincidence that the Annabelle
doll ends up in the hands of Mr. and Mrs.
Higgins’s next door neighbor, Mia Forme.
Perhaps it was one of the cult’s evocation
spells that caused the doll to be moved so
close to home.
On October 2nd 1967, twelve years after her
adoption into the Higgins family and roughly
a decade after she ran away, Janice, now known
as Annabelle, would come home.
"Annabelle Comes Home. Rated R."
Nope. It’s still not you.
As part of a ritual to call upon Malthus,
Janice and her boyfriend invade her adoptive
parents home one evening and slit their throats
before heading next door to steal back the
doll. This fulfills the blood sacrifice requirement
of the evocation spell.
Part of the ritual to reawaken the demon also
seems to involve Janice offering herself while
holding the doll in her arms and possibly
leaving this A symbol on the wall in red paint.
Or maybe she just felt that was an improvement
to the wallpaper of the nursery. I kind of
like it.
The summoning ritual seems to do the trick,
because the next day, unexplainable occurrences
start happening in John and Mia's house, including
a sewing machine turning on in the middle
of the night, the doll moving on its own,
and the day after that, unprovoked movement
of a rocking chair.
Mia tells her husband she can’t bear to
have the doll anymore.
“That doll. You have to get rid of it. I
mean, she had it in her hands.”
But like the time Linda tried to dump the
doll down the well it somehow appears again.
It seems that if Malthus has its target set
on you, there’s nothing you can do to actually
get rid of the Annabelle doll. Unlike the
penguin from Mario 64.
*sad penguin noises*
On October 5th, Malthus starts a fire in the
Form’s kitchen, and when a pregnant Mia
tries to get away, she is AIR YEETED back
towards the flames.
Thinking the house is haunted or something,
John and Mia move to Pasadena after Mia delivers
the baby. This is one of the classic horror
movie blunders. Malthus simply follows them
there and continues to mess with them by screwing
with the TV and using the appearance of the
child and teenage Janice to scare Mia and
get inside her head. Or at least something
that looks like Janice. I mean Malthus is a pretty
important demon, who I’m sure can’t be
bothered by little trivial details like what
Janice actually looks like.
I also talked earlier about how Malthus was
able to exploit the negative emotions of the
Mullins when they were in mourning. It uses
similar tactics here by listening in on John
and Mia’s conversations about the stress
caused by their new parenthood and John’s
job to divide them even further.
Malthus seems to focus it’s attacks on when
Mia is home alone with the baby to make her
feel further isolated, like on October 7th
when it lures her into the living room while
hiding behind the curtain, a little trick
it picked up from Bee, then blasting her to
the ground and running away in the form of
Janice, or whatever.
With Mia, Malthus is taking a somewhat similar
approach as it did with the Mullins. Instead
of tricking them into giving up their souls
with the false promise of speaking to their
daughter again, Malthus is pretending to go
after the soul of the baby, in hopes that
Mia will offer her soul in exchange for her
child’s safety.
“Demon’s can’t just take souls Mia.
A soul needs to be offered before it can take
it.”
“And a baby cannot offer it’s soul.”
So the next night, Malthus does everything
it can to make Mia feel that her baby is in
danger. After putting Lia to bed, she goes
to the basement to put some stuff into storage
when she hears the sound of a baby fussing
and a carriage appears at the end of the room.
She investigates to find that the stroller
is actually empty, and that this is a trap
devised by Malthus in its true form. Malthus
grabs her forearm and scratches the “A”
symbol onto it. The creature rises up to a
terrifying height as she runs away, and the
elevator won’t operate when she tries to
ride it to safety, forcing her to run back
through the basement to get to the stairs.
She hears her baby crying as she runs out
a virtual suicide squeeze back to her apartment,
but trips and drops her flashlight. When she
looks back over the edge she realizes Malthus
is right below her, almost the same scenario
as when Linda saw Malthus in the bunk below
her at the Mullins’ farmhouse.
When she gets to her floor, she looks back
and sees Malthus, growling and staring at
her from less than one full light of stairs
below. Then, during one lightning strike,
it has INSTANTLY advanced up to her level,
before she sprints the rest of the way into
her apartment. This is one of the only times
we actually see Malthus use this method of
extremely fast movement or possibly teleportation,
but it does help explain something about Annabelle
Creation. Specifically the part where it scares
the girls out of the downstairs bedroom, then
is already waiting for them when they run
to the barn.
Some unspecified amount of time goes by. It’s
long enough that the scratch on Mia’s arm
has fully healed. On the way home from a book
store, she hears Janice / Annabelle whisper
her name, and the baby stroller rolls into
the street and gets the old Gage Creed treatment
from a garbage truck. Luckily for her, Lia
wasn’t in the stroller, but this is all
part of Malthus’s plan to make her feel
like giving up her soul is the only way to
save the baby.
It continues this narrative later, when it
traps Mia in the nursery and bombards the
baby with a barrage of heavy books off the
bookshelf. Mia is able to break out of the
room to get to her daughter, so Malthus terrifies
her by lifting up the Annabelle doll while
staring at her from the shadows with bloodshot
eyes.
A terrified John and Mia send the doll away
with their priest, Father Perez, so Malthus
goes along for the ride, lending more credence
to my theory that there is some kind of binding
force between the demon and the doll.
On the drive, Malthus interrupts the Father’s
baseball game by messing with the radio. Rude.
Just rude.
The Father tries to bring the doll into the
church, and Malthus, perhaps remembering the
pain inflicted by being locked away and surrounded
by holy items, channels a ton of its power
and AIR YEETS Father Perez into the street.
Janice, or at least Malthus in its Janice
form, takes the doll back to return it to
Mia.
When John discovers what happened to Father
Perez, he tries to call and warn his wife,
but Malthus messes with the phone lines. It’s
interesting to me that a demon that existed
long before electronic technology does so
much tampering with phones, TVs and radios,
but it makes sense that it would try to deceive
humans using their primary methods of communication.
Just as it used a nun form before taking the
soul of Janice, it now uses the form of Father
Perez to stage it’s final attack on her.
“May God have mercy on your soul!”
It pulls out all of the stops to try to convince
Mia to offer her soul, like playing demonic
chanting over the record player, disfiguring
the dolls in the nursery, crawling on the
ceiling and even kidnapping Lia, which sends
Mia into a desperate search for her daughter
that culminates in her asking.
“What do you want from me?”
…And getting her answer written on the ceiling,
before getting the revised answer written
on the opening window. This is a parallel
to Janice offering the knife to Linda in 1955.
It’s a suggestion for Mia to give her life
so that Malthus can harvest her soul, but
at the end of the day, she must be the one
to give herself up.
John arrives just in time to save Mia from
throwing her life away, however, Malthus still
ending up getting what it wanted in the end
when their friend Evelyn gives her own soul
in Mia’s stead. So Malthus does win this
round, but the Form family gets their baby
back, and the Annabelle doll disappears from
their lives.
In April of 1968, the doll somehow ended up
in a gift shop, and where a woman who claimed
to have been looking everywhere for one of
Mr Mullins's limited edition dolls picked
it up and gave it to her daughter, Camilla,
as a birthday present.
Like with each of the previous victims, Camilla
and her roommate Debbie start to notice small
paranormal occurrences that ramp up over the
months that would follow.
At first they would just notice the doll’s
hand or leg move. Then it would move from
room to room when they were gone. They hired
a medium, who seemed to successfully make
contact with the spirit of Annabelle Higgins
-- not realizing that she was actually talking
to Malthus. Malthus told the medium that Annabelle
passed away in their apartment long ago and
wanted permission to move into the doll and
be friends with the nurses that lived there.
As we know by now, this was all a trick. They
began to find unsettling notes, which lead
up to Malthus vandalizing their spare room.
They try throwing the doll into the dumpster…
but as we know by now that doesn’t work
either. Debbie finds another ominous note
and they discover the Annabelle doll sitting
back in the apartment once more.
Something also happens between the doll and
one of their boyfriends, though it's not clear
exactly what. Realising they’re in more
trouble than the medium led them to believe,
they decide to call in the big help, and contact
renowned demonologists Ed and Lorraine Warren.
The Warrens explain how the inhuman spirit
tricked them.
“You gave it permission to infest your lives.”
Before things get any worse, Ed and Lorraine
call the church to have a priest sent in and
bless the apartment and its inhabitants, which
seemed to do the trick. I think Malthus knew
what it was up against here and decided to
calm down for the time being.
The Warrens would take the doll with them
for safe keeping. Annabelle -- was finally
-- coming home.
“Annabelle Comes Home.
Annabelle Comes Home.
Rated R.
Comes. Comes. Comes.
Annabelle Comes Home.
Rated R.
Annabelle Comes.
Comes. Annabelle.
Annabelle Comes Home.
Experience it in IMAX.
As Ed and Lorraine head back home after finally
securing the Annabelle doll, their car breaks
down next to a cemetery in Maryville. Given
Malthus’s tendency to mess with lights,
TVs, radios, telephones, record players, elevators
and chair lifts, I’m sure this breakdown
was probably a result of the evil entity associated
with the doll.
Malthus decided to do this next to a cemetery
because of another powerful attribute this
demon possesses.
“It’s the doll Ed. It’s a beacon for
other spirits.”
So all of the lingering spirits from the graveyard
are drawn to Malthus, who is latched onto
the doll, and Malthus is able to manipulate
these spirits into doing its bidding. One
of them pushes Ed into the street in front
of a speeding truck. Jud Crandall would not
have been pleased.
“Don’t let him go in the road Lewis!”
Malthus takes over the truck, so that the
driver has no control and tries to take out
Ed, who is just barely able to dodge the oncoming
vehicle. The inhuman spirit was far more powerful
than they anticipated.
Their priest, Father Gordon, is waiting for
them when they arrive home. As they take Annabelle
to the artifact room, the doll stares at their
young daughter Judy, perhaps perceiving her
as a weaker target.
At first, they leave the doll in a rocking
chair, but it causes complete chaos, making
clocks run backwards and influencing the other
artifacts to come to life. A simple blessing
and splash of holy water is not enough to
contain it, so they build a glass case using
material from Trinity Church chapel.
The doll gains a reputation as the Warrens’
most malevolent item -- at least at the time.
It would continue to be housed at their home
in Monroe, Connecticut and be blessed twice a month
by a priest.
It would remain there for the next three years.
In 1971, while the Warrens are investigating
a case in Rhode Island, they bring back the
spirit of a witch named Bathsheba. Because
Bathsheba is particularly malicious, and because
Malthus is a beacon for other spirits, the
witch becomes attracted to the doll and frees
it from the protective casing. In the middle
of the night, Bathsheba takes the doll out
into one of the rooms.
Judy is woken up by Bathsheba pulling at her
ankle and investigates the house. She finds
Bathsheba rocking on a chair and combing Annabelle’s
hair in one of the rooms. Malthus turns Annabelle’s
head to give the appearance that the doll
itself is turning to stare at Judy.
She tries to exit the room, but finds that
she’s locked in, and the two malevolent
spirits have disappeared from human sight.
This is a potentially disastrous situation,
you have one inexperienced young medium trapped
inside with two powerful and malicious supernatural
entities. One of them starts hurling furniture
at her, but luckily Ed and Lorranine get home
in time to come to the rescue her before she
takes on any damage.
Ed checks the cursed artifact room to see
if anything is out of order, but by that time
Annabelle is back in the glass case, so this
potential catastrophe ends up being more of
a minor incident, but perhaps this also reinvigorated
the demon’s spirit.
The following year, in September 1972, shortly
before Judy Warren’s birthday party that
year, a girl named Daniela Rios sneaks into
the Warrens’ artifact room and places a
photo of her deceased father on the piano,
hoping to find a way to make contact with
the other side to talk to him.
Malthus senses that she’s a vulnerable target
because she’s in mourning, just like Mr.
and Mrs. Mullins were. She asks for a sign
from any presence that might be in the room,
so Malthus leans the Annabelle doll forward
against the glass. This causes Daniela to
open the case and pick up the doll, but just
then a smoke alarm from the kitchen sends
her quickly on her way. However, she forgets
to lock the case back up and Annabelle is
finally able to escape again.
As a beacon for other spirits, Malthus is
able to release many more horrifying entities
from the objects that they are bound to. A
few of them include The Ferryman, The Black
Shuck, The Haunted Wedding Dress of Anna Baker
and others.
After escaping its prison, the Annabelle doll
sits at the kitchen table as Judy’s babysitter,
Mary-Ellen, orders a pizza. The doorbell rings,
accompanied by the familiar set of three knocks.
When Mary Ellen looks through the peephole,
no one is there, but when she opens the door,
she sees Bee, who asks if Annabelle can come
play.
When Mary-Ellen says she has the wrong house,
she tells her to look right behind her, but
the doll is now gone.
Malthus takes on different forms for different
people to try to deceive them. In Daniela’s
case, it uses the form of her father, which
is part of Malthus’s plan to lul her into
a sense of security.
Later on, Judy senses something going on upstairs
and sees the bride associated with the haunted
wedding dress go into one of the rooms. However,
this can’t just be the ghost on its own,
because she finds a note that says “Miss
Me?” just like the nurses did when Malthus
began terrorizing them. So when the bride
comes at her with a knife, it’s likely being
driven by Malthus.
Later that night, Malthus continues to haunt
Judy by hiding the remote under the couch
and frightening her with the Annabelle doll
when she goes to look for it.
The Black Shuck is a werewolf like creature
that guards the perimeter of the house, preventing
Mary-Ellen’s love interest, Bob from offering
help to the three girls. Daniela, is lured
into the cursed artifact room again when Malthus
leaves the door unlocked to tempt her.
She tries using the Mourning Bracelet, an
item said to let someone connect with a deceased
loved one. While this bracelet does work for
Lorraine under the right circumstances, Malthus
inferes with it by pretending to be her dad.
She sees his face appear in the mirror, but
when she turns to look at him, one of his
eyes is missing, much like Mrs. Mullins. Malthus
probably saw how much the one eyed Mrs. Mullins
scared the girls back at the farmhouse and
decided to try to use it again on Daniela.
That’s probably what makes Malthus one of
the cleverest and most dangerous inhuman spirits
in the Conjuring franchise -- it never forgets
an old trick. So the longer it sticks around,
the more tactics it learns, and the better
it gets at deceiving its prey and coercing
them to give up their souls. That fact that
it still uses Bee Mullins as one of its forms
29 years after her death, just proves that
Malthus always still has an old trick at its
disposal.
As with the Mullins and Form residence hauntings
before, Malthus ramps things up throughout
the night to try to put its victims on edge.
First it shatters Mary-Ellen’s milk glass,
then randomly turns on the radio. When she
checks in on the sleeping Judy, Mary-Ellen
discovers the Annabelle doll under the covers.
She finds it kind of disturbing, but doesn’t
know the doll is attached to an evil entity,
so doesn’t think much of it. When she goes
back downstairs, the TV is on.
Malthus also messes with a TV inside the artifact
the room where Daniela is. This time, instead
of pulling out another old trick, it puts
a new one on display by making the television
show what happens a few seconds into the future.
Like many of the strange things that happen
in The Conjurverse, this phenomenon isn’t
ever explained, but I personally think it’s
actually very simple.
If Lorraine has a clairvoyant ability, which
allows her to foresee future events, like
her daughter being in danger in The Conjuring
1 and her husband being in danger in The Conjuring
2, who’s to say that Malthus doesn’t also
have a touch of clairvoyance? And since we’ve
already seen that Malthus has the ability
to make any electronics go haywire, it doesn’t
seem like too much of a stretch for it to
be able to display these future events on
a TV screen.
Meanwhile, Mary-Ellen hears a tape player
playing audio of Ed and Lorraine’s case
file on their investigation of The Ferryman,
evil spirit set loose by Malthus. She find
the source of the audio and turns it off.
The Ferryman is known for putting coins over
the eyes of its victims, and she follows a
trail of coins until she sees a pair of them
seemingly floating on the ceiling. We saw
Malthus hide on the ceiling before attacking
both Carol in 1955 and Evelyn in 1967. So
seeing the Ferryman use this approach
means that Malthus was probably involved.
It’s likely using the Ferryman as a conduit
in the same way we saw Valak use the ghost
of Bill Wilkins in the Conjuring 2.
Mary-Ellen runs for it, but she trips on something
and gets AIR YEETED back into the dark. Using
her flashlight, she’s able to temporarily
free herself from the evil spirit’s grip.
She immediately high-tails it to Judy’s
room, but Judy would have her own confrontation
in which Malthus would bring out it’s full
arsenal of alternate forms.
Judy sleeps next to a revolving color wheel
lamp, a novelty item that dates back to the
1950s. This lamp would have an usual effect
on the demon, Malthus. It begins with Malthus
dragging Judy by the ankle to wake her up.
This is exactly how Bathsheba woke up her
victims in The Conjuring, though it’s not
clear if Bathsheba actually escaped the music
box it was captured in, or if Malthus just
learned this from the witch’s ghost when
they met the previous year.
When she wakes up, Judy quickly realizes something
is wrong when she discovers the Annabelle
doll underneath the covers with her. Bee appears
from under the covers at the foot of the bed
and scares her, causing her to knock over
the color wheel. It continues to spin and
project it’s colored light onto the wall.
As each color changes, a different form of
Malthus is displayed. It starts with the doll,
then Bee, then the adult version of Janice,
and finally the rarely seen “true form”
of Malthus.
It then appears behind her on the bed and
screeches at her. She bolts out of the room,
where Mary-Ellen is waiting for her. With
the Black Shuck outside, they realize they’re
trapped in. They place a call to Lorraine
for help, but Malthus has manipulated the
phone lines as well.
LORRAINE: “Can I speak to Annabelle?”
MARY-ELLEN: “I’m sorry?”
LORRAINE: “You need to give her a soul,
dear.”
MARY-ELLEN: “What?”
LORRAINE: “A soul? She wants her soul. Give
me her soul.”
That’s even more annoying than telemarketers.
Well… no maybe not that annoying.
Before trying to make an attempt on one of
their souls, all of the bells in the house
start ringing, which might be another callback
to Mrs. Mullins, who had a bedside handbell
to request help. Then the typewriter goes
all Jack Torrance and writes the words “Miss
Me” over and over. A phone starts ringing
in the artifact room, and Judy and Mary-Ellen
get in there just in time to stop Daniela
from touching it. She admits to being the
one who let Annabelle out of the case, and
has bad news regarding the other spirits in
the room.
JUDY: “What else did you touch?”
DANIELA: “Everything.”
This sends Mary-Ellen into an asthma attack,
but as Judy goes to fetch her inhaler, the
creepy bride sneaks up on Daniela, using the
same teleport forward mechanic that Malthus
used on Mia Form in the stairwell.
It appears that she’s stabbed Daniela in
the stomach, but it is only an illusion. She
pins her to the ground and pukes inside of
her mouth, so for the first time since Janice
in 1955, Malthus has a new vessel.
After Judy safely returns with the inhaler,
Daniela tries to beckon the two of them to
go upstairs, but Judy, taking after her mother’s
medium abilities, senses something is wrong
and leads Mary-Ellen to try to find the Annabelle
doll so they can put an end to the horror
they were living through that night.
They find the cursed childrens toy in the
closet inside the Warrens’ office, but the
door is locked, so they have to play this
board game, Feely Meely in order to win the
key. I found it a bit strange that this evil
inhuman spirit would just stop in the middle
of everything to strike up a board game with
these kids, but when I went back, I realized
that the game is seen in the room of cursed
objects at the beginning, so this is probably
another trial where Malthus is manipulating
whatever evil spirit was living in this board
game.
Judy is able to win the key, and Mary-Ellen
ventures into the closet, which now resembles
the Ferryman’s tombs. She’s only able
to toss the doll back to Judy before being
pulled back into the abyss, but Judy recovers
the fumble and makes a break for the end zone
before being met with Daniela, who is infused
with both the evil of Malthus and the ire
of the wedding dress spirit.
Mary-Ellen comes in with a key block and Big
Brain Judy’s fast thinking probably saves
a couple lives when she turns on a projector
with a recording of Ed performing an exorcism.
This essentially seems to have the same effect
as him performing the actual exorcism and
causes immense pain to the demonic presence
inside of her.
This buys them just enough time to get Annabelle
back to its case, but when Judy opens it Malthus
slams it shut, corners her, and attempts to
suck out Judy’s soul using a Dementor’s
kiss. As you may know, the Dementor’s kiss
is an act performed by the wraithlike species
of prison guards in The Wizarding World (aka
the Harry Potter franchise) to suck out the
soul of anyone who gets in their way.
The Conjurverse and the Wizarding World may
both be Warner Bros. properties, but they
are not the same universe. However, Malthus
doesn’t seem to care, and nearly performs
the Dementor’s kiss on Judy. Mary-Ellen
tries to come in and save her, so Malthus
gets in one last AIR YEET and sends her flying
into the wall.
But this gives Judy just enough time to grab
a nearby cross, something she probably should
have gone for a while ago, and press it to
Malthus’s head. Mary-Ellen places the Annabelle
doll back into the chapel glass case, but
Malthus’s power prevents her from being
able to force it shut. Things look hopeless
as all of the escaped evil spirits from that
night surround them, but luckily for them,
Daniela shows up, now free of the demonic
possession. She is the only character that
we know of ever to be freed from Malthus’s
grip, and with her strength, they’re able
to force Annabelle’s case closed. I can
only imagine that Daniela never actually gave
in to the idea of Malthus taking her soul,
and that's why she was able to be exorcised.
The doll and the demonic presence bound to
it are once again sealed, and without the
spiritual beacon of the Annabelle doll, Malthus
and the other spirits are no longer able to
materialize in our world.
“The evil has been contained.”
And as far as we know, Malthus would remain
locked in Ed and Lorraine Warren’s cursed
artifact room from that point forward.
That concludes Malthus’s history in the
canon of the The Conjuring Universe movies,
but the real life story is perhaps open to
another chapter. Lorraine Warren passed away
in April of 2019 and left the cursed artifact
room, which is known in real life as the Warrens’
Occult Museum to her son in law, Tony Spera.
That’s Judy’s husband.
In 2020, because of course this would happen
in 2020, it was reported that The Annabelle
doll had somehow “escaped” and was now
missing from the room. Tony Spera took to
YouTube to shoot down those rumors.
“Annabelle’s here. She didn’t go anywhere.
She didn’t take a trip... So you know. Here
she is. Let’s put the rumors to rest guys.”
But during this fiasco, it also came out that
Tony and Judy were looking to relocate the
museum, which has been closed for some time
due to zoning issues. So it’s not hard to
imagine a future Conjurverse story where one
of the movers doesn’t take the proper precautions
with The Annabelle doll and Malthus is set
loose once more.
We’ve seen a lot of these “many years
later” horror sequels recently, so maybe
a modern day Annabelle sequel could eventually
be in the cards.
Let me know in the comments which other Conjurverse
characters or entities you’d like to see
covered next here on Horror History and if
you love horror remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, RING the deathbell,
not the spirit bell, for notifications and
I will see you in the next one. Assuming we
both survive.